Look, I've got some notes here
and, and all I want to say is this,
I want to play at one point that you
had about that. That was really good.
You were saying that if you
sense yourself, he's just like,
I'll just censor myself a little bit, just
a little bit there to make this point.
We started the show but the actual auto,
you made it in the back start
over and it and it's right you.
We were talking and we were, first
of all, we gave each other a big hug.
We talked it out.
We're both happy that we're not angry
at each other and then when we start
talking,
you made a really good point.
You said the thing is if you
sense yourself just 1% you say,
I'll just censor myself
1% that's what they want.
I'm going to make them happy and then
they're just going to keep moving it.
They're just going to keep moving
it forward. Moving the goalpost,
moving the goalposts and providing you
with more money and giving you more
things, but keep moving it in a certain
direction and if you keep giving into it,
they're going to have a hold of
you and they can control you.
And that's how network
television got started.
If you really think about what
ned for network television is,
the reason why they don't swear and
they don't have explicit content isn't
because people wouldn't want to see it.
The reason is because the,
the advertisers won't let them. There's
a whole commerce aspect to it. It's,
it's not just, hey, you're the
CSI guys or hey, you're exactly.
And so now they've organized with
sleeping giant and immediate matters.
A couple million people that call and
threaten and attack anybody and then
notice Joe, once they're
done with me, now it's Joe,
you better not have this person on or
you better have that person on and show
what is your goal?
What is your destiny worth?
And I always thought I was smart because
I got to analyze politics and history.
I was kind of socially retarded.
And so I'll think you'll
have to say that anymore.
Exactly what I was and so that's what
I'm getting at is the biggest liars
without people to know the truth.
I don't come up with some cold blooded
calculation about what I think's going to
advance my personal life. I really
care about people and the process.
I've seen things wrong. I've grown,
I've heard people, I apologize. Listen,
that's true. That's true. What
you're just saying about you,
and this is one of the things that
I've always tried to explain to people.
If people get mad at me for knowing him,
like I have a great time with that guy.
Every time I see him,
you and I have had a great time in Austin.
We had a great time with the UFC.
We've hung out a numerous comedy
shows that I've done in Austin.
I've done your show 20 years ago.
We've had a lot of fun together.
And so when when people get mad at you
about sandy hook or about anything,
I just go. Even when he's, even when
you were mad at me, I wasn't mad at you.
I was like, I just got to
talk to them. They're like,
it's one of the reasons why Eddie Bravo
got the two of us to talk yet once we
talk and just be honest with each other,
we'll be fine.
And I want to clear this up because
when I was going big guns on you,
just so you'd know what
it's like to be judged,
I thought that you probably
never had any show.
It was not an attempt to get
back on your show. Listen, I,
I knew that if I had gotten to the point
where you're that upset that I must
have made mistakes too.
I'm not,
I'm not that person that sees things and
always points in the other direction.
I pointed my, I'm a fucking
ruthless self critic ruthless.
I'm terrible. Like, so I beat
myself up about every house.
I'll flub one word on stage and I'll
sleep through the Ami tossing and turning
me. Send this to you. And again,
self doubts, a good thing.
It's just not going to be
a narcissist and crazy. Um,
I got offered at the time like
$5 million with a bitcoin.
I think it was like $38 billion by the
time it got there. I refused it. And I,
and I got told like eight years ago,
I got told by two different people,
a very well known rich people.
They said Jordan Charles,
like she wants to work with you and
Alexandra Soros and his other Soros.
You just need to stop attacking.
Mm. And, and by the way,
we want you to pump bitcoin,
which may I believe in cryptocurrencies.
I believe it's the future. And we had a
private Federal Reserve. It's all Fiat.
I'm not judging anybody,
I'm just saying be careful.
And I was showed dumb back then.
I don't need even say so dumb.
I was not in the current mindset,
the way the world worked.
Like I knew how politics worked and I
knew how science worked and I knew how
crypto type, you know,
government and CIA stuff worked.
But I was like never trying to get a deal
for myself. I had my own thing. Right.
So then I looked back in retrospect where,
where that was going on.
So when I saw you, it was
my breaking point. Go, Hey,
Alex Jones is full of
crap. George Soros, uh,
was a victim of the Nazis and the
Holocaust. And that's not what I said.
I didn't see your full crop. I said he
wasn't a Nazi. I go to the story that I,
I watched the interview and I don't
know what he did. He know the guy.
I don't know him. I don't know.
I've know very little about him.
But what I remember from the story was
that he was saying that when the Nazis
occupied,
he was with his,
I believe it was his own.info
Godfather his godfather,
and took him around as a Christian
and pretended he was a Christian.
Whether they were stealing from these
Jews when they would take take there.
And he just thought it was normal
because he was 13 years old.
But he was talking about it,
that he was shielded by this person.
I would be willing to take his
explanation is what I'm saying, but,
but, but, but, but here's the difference.
Even before that happened with you,
I got approached by a
major Hollywood actor, uh,
that my name's Herbert associated
with. And they said, listen,
George Soros told me to tell you that
he'd been killed if he didn't do that and
that and that and that. He did what
he had to do. Right. And I shed.
You tell George if somebody
put a gun to my head and shed,
we're going to kill you if you don't help
round up Joe Rogan's kids and put them
in a concentration camp, I'd
say, Oh yeah, I agree with you.
I've got the gun away and kill him.
Did he say,
he just said it was just
taking property? No, they were,
what do you think was even Nazi show up?
Take your property and then you don't go
away. I don't know. I mean, I don't know.
We know what happened in
Romania and Hungary but,
but Joe [inaudible] what he was saying,
they have headlines saying, okay,
so you're saying you think
that it was more, no, no,
he did an NPR interview. I'm not
trying to go indict George Soros. Okay,
well here's where I fucked up cause I
shouldn't have even said anything about it
cause I don't know much about it.
The real absolute honesty I've seen.
I've seen a couple of interpretation when
I was horrible to interpretation from
me. I'm telling you, I don't know
anything about it was incorrect. Sure.
So when I'm 14 and I, in retrospect,
if somebody shed, we're going to,
you're going to help round up your
community or we're going to kill you.
I would have tried to kill people that
were trying to kill people. I get it.
Not Everybody's like me and I'm not
trying to the top of sky around.
I think I've proven, I'll go up
against people. I get, you're 14,
you're scared and you helped the Nazis.
He was show arrogant about it.
He said it on NPR.
He started on 60 minutes and then I
learned you're being sued because you did
this. This is why he's financing. Well,
I'm not going to stop shaking
it because of that. I get,
he was in a bad situation.
The problem was if you play the clip,
he says it was the best time of my life.
It was happy making. Uh, it was,
it was invigorating to be there
with all this evil going on.
But I was with my father and I had faith
in him. And so we were able to do this.
And then I went and looked at
the logs and the records of him.
He was like going around looking for
Anne Frank's man and getting their money.
And Alan, yeah, he got the
money. There's some like I'm not,
I'm not even just run up a
white flag to George Soros.
George Soros overthrew all these
different governments towards swirls,
tried to crash the pound.
George Soros is the,
is the art type of James Bond
Villains and the fact that his money,
so I remember being a kid when I was like,
uh,
eight years old. My mom always
had a color TV in the kitchen,
but she cooked three meals a
day. Can I stop you? What do you,
what are you saying that
he's like crashing economies.
And when I was a kid watching PBS and
maybe they were lying, maybe he's great.
George Soros was an international currency
speculator who overthrew governments,
you know, booty. Yeah. But that's
what I'm saying. What do you, what,
what are you saying over through
governments? Like, what did he do?
I literally know nothing. Well,
here's what I'm going to tell you.
This is actually a declassified. You
know anything about George Soros? Jamie,
they'll type in George Soros
crashing the pound. Let me tell you,
born in George Soros is view.
After World War II,
he got hired,
brought to the u s he worked for the CIA.
LSS before that.
In his view, from his perspective, he
admitted he doesn't Brag about this.
George Soros is the guy willing
to take the money and DB it out,
and he's a very bold guy because
he's really small. I mean,
I'm not kissing his ass her, get him
on my back. He's not gonna stop me,
wants to hang my hat on the wall towards
while it does have 150 why does he want
to hang your head on the wall?
Because I went after him.
But the point is it doesn't matter.
George Soros ran the breakup
of the Soviet Union. George,
I've,
I've had the former head of of of you
got Jamie kind of thing type deal.
George Soros tried to crash the pound
the pound.
Anyways, guys, let me tell you, I
told you they got human pig hype.
You'd be putting them in it. Okay. I
told you they're keeping babies alive.
You saw the governor said George
Soros is highest level deep state.
He, he is the manager or was the manager.
Are you shooting of a secret payment?
Things you're saying,
I actually know,
but how do you know if he
leaves the research? He ran the,
cause I'm not the auction was 10
years ago he ran the Marshall.
We got here, George Soros break the Bank
of England mixed a little bigger police
in Britain.
Black Wednesday,
September 16 prior to the day of
the speculators broke the pound.
They didn't actually break it,
but they forced the British government
to pull it from the European exchange
rate mechanism. Joining the
erm, the king, the euro,
the pound, the euro, scrolling up please.
All those to depart from the European
currencies, the British pound, blah, blah,
blah.
Compounding the underlying
problems inherent in the
pounds inclusion in the erm,
I'm not seeing this.
Where's the part where George Soros doses?
Well that's just what you
pulled up. I mean, but I'm just,
I'm just trying to find it.
That's all I'm saying.
Spotting of the writing on the wall,
Britain updates interest rates to
teens and attract people to the pound,
but speculate is George Soros among them
began heavily shorting the currency the
British government gave in
and withdrew its erm, the erm,
as it became clear that it was
losing billions trying to, boy,
it's currency artificially, although it
was a bit of a bitter pill to swallow,
the pound came back stronger because the
excess interest in high inflation force
out of, as you go to investors,
PDA like it's the boss. Hold on.
There's films about the Soros,
Soros,
Soros pocketed $1 billion on the deal
and cemented his reputation as the
premiere currency speculator in the world.
Now,
if you're a currency speculator,
isn't that what you do though?
I don't know what a currency speculator
does it. I don't want it. Here's the deal.
George Soros works for the works for the
people that run our government and he's
a guy willing to do at all and
he's been very successful. Okay.
My point is two plus two equals
four in my, in my equation.
You don't fight the Nazis because
you're 1314 you think you can't.
You join him. And he says, he talked
to me about the investment. I, I,
if I wouldn't have done it, someone
else would've done it. That's a quote.
It was happy making good. If you help
roundup Jews and take their property,
don't say it was happy making you don't
talk about it. So my point is him,
Shango you, you think the way he describes
it, even as a problem, it's problematic.
It disturbs you the way
he's describing that.
It was happy making that it was not a
big deal if I didn't do what other people
have done it.
That's a problem.
What I'm telling you is I'm going to
get off into Soros, is that if you,
if I had five minutes over there on
Jamie's computer, needed a good job.
Jamie does a great job. I'm
just saying it. Pull stuff up.
He's a goddamn Google wizard. Look at
him. LE, he's been beat me at quick too.
It's very frustrating.